Japan is really interesting when it
comes to weight loss because we're one
of the most healthy scholars in the
world and yet I think it's something
ridiculous like one in three people diet
it's crazy right and I'm like you don't
need to diet because I and that whole
you know that whole thing comes from the
whole ridiculous standard of everyone
here and well everybody needs to be
bulimic otherwise you're not considered
beautiful yeah but look going back to
the fruit thing I I remember me and Aki
went to like this new supermarket that
opened up near our place yeah
and I wanted to check out the fruit
section because I'm always curious I'm
like how can we get ripped off anymore
and they would like these packet of
there were these cherries right I love
eating cherries no these packet of like
cherries from America
yeah which will like that was like 30 of
them in there and it was like 400 yen
I'm like okay a tad expensive but not
too bad right next to there there was a
pack of another 30 cherries but they
were from like Ibaraki or like somewhere
local and it was obviously some kind of
brand right
guess how much these cherries would just
going off Japan experienced like 30
bucks I guess like 3,000 yen how much do
you think it was like 2500 yen yeah mm
oh yeah Nora 25 bucks yeah think of a
6500 George but 30 cherries homegrown
okay like what like I said Lane I was
really tempted to buy just like I swear
to God if one cherry doesn't give me an
orgasm like it's good it's good fruit
don't get me wrong yeah is it worth the
[ __ ] premium that I'm paying hey I
don't think so Oh like like it's already
a luxury just to buy regular firm yeah
yeah regular non-branded for exactly
it's like who is buying this that's
that's my biggest concern is late
what kind of fertile eatest is like
buying these like $60 cherries from like
down the road you buy Mitchell enjoy
cherries and be like yes I can
definitely taste like the harm grown
quality in this it's so it's the [ __ ]
elderly is the grandma oh yeah this is
hidden health benefits
cherry will fix your erectile
dysfunction this isn't from America it's
our own going back to you know people
who stay thin in Japan I think one
preconception the Hat is that I would
just move to Japan and because because
Japanese food is so healthy you just
like lose weight automatically I'd like
zero efforts lose weight or somatically
most restaurants have a menu surprise
surprise Reina if you just pick the
unhealthy option you read the unhealthy
yeah yeah you gain just as much I think
that whole preconception is that like I
think especially when it comes from like
Americans yeah it's just it's not so
much about like the actual fact that
like the food is healthier and I'm sure
like if you like constantly don't eat
out of like traditional Japanese
restaurant yes traditional Japanese food
yes you're probably getting healthier
stuff yeah but I think it just seems
healthier especially when compared to
like Americans because the portion sizes
are just smaller that yeah and like the
whole combini all that stuff is
definitely not healthy
oh no it's delicious that's the problem
like everything's delicious so you just
want to keep asking more and more right
I think we like we mistake it is like a
food culture thing as to why everyone's
so thin here but it's definitely like
when you live here you realize really
quickly it's a lifestyle thing yeah cuz
they walk so much
most people do exercise and less that
super busy with work and yeah that's
already draining enough but I've noticed
that people don't really like eat lunch
or breakfast much here it's like a light
bye most of the time unless it's a
business meal yeah that's when they'll
eat lunch but most people I think just
have like an onigiri or like a small
snack and only a calorie mate right and
even then I think most people are just
too exhausted by the time they finished
work they just have something just cuz
they need to yeah and then they go to
bed well I mean when you're a youtuber
like I eat because I'm bored and trust
me there is more than enough stuff to
eat here that is like terrible